شخصيات عديده بقيت طويلا حبيسه الوثائق في
المحاكم خرجت الى دائره الضوء وقد تكفي
شهادتها لتغيير مصير امريكا السياسي
لسنوات ابرزها دون منازع القاضي
الذي يستعد لدخول غرفه جنايات محكمه منهت
جارا معه كيان رئيس سابق في مشهد ليس له
ما قبله وان كان المكان غير مالوف فالمضيف
ليس كذلك حتى ان ترونت حاكمه غيابيا قبل
المثول امامه القاضي الذي تم تعيينه في
اطار حمله مطارده الساحرات التي تنفذ ضدي
لم يشرف من قبل على قضايا مماثله وهو بكل
بساطه يكرهني خوان مرشان لم يدر قضيه
شخصيه للترومب لكنه حام كثيرا حوله
وفي كل مره كانت النتائج واحده اخر فصول
المواجهه شهدتها المحكمه نفسها نهايه
العام الماضي وكلفت منظمه ترومب مليونا
وسته مئه الف دولار ثمنا لتهربها الضريبي
اضافه الى سجن مديرها
خمسه اشهر القاضي الاكثر قساوه كما وصفه
ترامب وله في ذلك حجه اخرى اسابيع قليله
قبل المحاكمه الاخيره وقف مستشار ترامب
السابق ستيف بانون امام مرشان بتهم اختلاس
اموال تبرعات جمعت بهدف بناء جدار على طول
الحدود مع المكسيك ومره اخرى كان السجن
مصيرا المتهم هي صدفه او ربما طبيعه حكمه
القاسيه هناك سبب اخر يقلق دفاع ترامب
ميول مرشان الديمقراطي يصعب اخفائه سنوات
خبره قليله في محكمه نيويورك قضاها في
اداره منا تتعلق بالاسره كانت كافيه
ليرشحه الديمقراطيون لتولي منصب المدعي
العام الفيدرالي ايام حكم اوباما النظام
الامريكي يعتمد اساسا على تقدير هيئه
المحلفين ودور القاضي يقتصر في اداره
الجلسه وتكييف العقوبه بعد الادانه الا ان
ترامب شكك منذ البدايه بعداله المحكمه في
تحدي اخر يواجهه الديمقراطيون بعد ان رفض
هو وانصاره الاعتراف بمشروعيه الانتخابات